ستيفاني أوبوغو هي مسافر دائم فخور
بالإحباط بشكل متكرر من قبل
شركات الطيران التي أرادت منا
الاستفادة من السفر ، ثم فعلنا ذلك في
النهاية ، ويبدو الأمر كما لو أن ستيفاني ، انتظر ، انتظر الآن ،
لقد أصبحت ستيفاني مجرد واحدة من
الموالين لشركة دلتا إيرلاينز التي تغضب من
القواعد الجديدة التالية  في العام ، تجعل الشركة من
الصعب الوصول إلى أكثر من 50
صالة من صالات Sky Club في المطارات حول العالم ،
يشعر العملاء بالضيق بسبب الخطوط الخارجية
والمقاعد المزدحمة بالداخل
لإخبار المسافرين الدائمين بأننا اتخذنا
القرار الصعب لتنفيذ
سياسات جديدة نعتقد أنها ستحافظ
على  تجربة يستحق ضيوفنا ، يقول سكوت
كيز من رحلات سكوت الرخيصة ، إن
شركات الطيران تقلل من الامتيازات الآن بعد
أن عادت أرقام السفر بالقرب
من مستويات ما قبل الوباء وتتوقع شركة يونايتد إيرلاينز
السفر في عطلة نهاية العام
أكبر من عيد الشكر الماضي
في العام المقبل.  شريط
الحصول على حالة المسافر الدائم يجعل من
الصعب الحصول على ترقيات مجانية
والتنازل عن الرسوم  من
الصعب جدًا الوصول إلى الصالات أكثر
صعوبة لتجديد حالة النخبة
وأكثر صعوبة لاسترداد
أميال المسافر الدائم الخاصة بهم لرحلة مجانية ، فإن رحلة طيران دلتا
من LAX إلى JFK خلال عطلة الربيع
تكلفك عادةً 25000
ميل من أميال المسافر الدائم مقابل رحلة مجانية.  مقعد اقتصادي الآن
تقول رحلات سكوت الرخيصة إنها ستكلف
أكثر من ضعف ما
يقوله المدافعون عن المستهلكين إن كسب الأميال
لم يكن أسهل بفضل
بطاقات الائتمان الخاصة بشركات الطيران ، لكن استبدال الأميال أصبح الآن
أكثر صرامة لشركات الطيران لأنهم
يفتقدون العلامة هنا ، وآمل أن
يستمعون إلى المستهلك ويفكرون حقًا
في بعض القرارات التي
يتخذونها على المستوى الأعلى Pete
mundine CNN Washington